[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to another
English language lesson today we will
focus on uh a very interesting part of
reading
comprehension and we're going to uh
detect logical fallacies in uh the
reading passages that we've been
covering in the past videos
uh so let's move on as you can see here
in the video
uh and you can understand from the same
words that some uh passages and some
statements or claims or opinions are uh
not to make sense so they don't they
don't make sense that's why they're
called
fallacies uh the objectives of this
lesson uh are three and uh the first one
is that by the end of the class the
student are are are going to make the
difference are going to see the
difference between uh a statement and
opinion and a fact second one is that
students are going to spot logical
fallacies in a uh students perspective
maybe perhaps an academic writing and
reading passages and speaking and
listening as well and the third
objective is uh that students are going
to be able to uh write a paper that
doesn't use logical fallacies and know
how to fix papers that
do so uh the first
one we will focus on uh introducing the
term logical fallacy what are some
common logical fallacies and uh we're
going to put that knowledge into
practice uh by the end of the video
uh being persuasive in a communication
process is a tough job especially if
you're a student you need the right
amount of Art in terms of delivery and
the right amount of Integrity in your
words and their context and uh not being
able to properly deliver a message is
nothing compared to not having Integrity
in what you say so in this lesson we
will learn how to spot logical fallacies
in communication in writing and reading
and why not figure out why they are
wrong so we don't have to uh make the
same mistakes when we uh right or speak
to
someone uh so a broad a broad definition
of logical
fallaces is uh known to be as a common
flaw so those are common flaws in
reasoning that weaken or uh invalidate
someone's arguments logic and and
fallacies can be either invalid
arguments or irrelevant points and they
are frequently discovered due to the
absence of evidence to support the
assertion and a good communicator is
able to
recognize and uh understand why that
logic doesn't work or wh why is that a
fallacy uh as well as uh good
communicators are able to uh avoid
falling victim to a logical
fallacy
some of the most common logical
fallacies are Hasty generalization
slippery slope ad homonym and red
hering Hasty generalization is uh a
conclusion that is based on insufficient
evidence or
information uh this logical fallacy is
committed when a uh conclusion is drawn
from a haste or uh an insufficient
evidence and uh uh if we can take an
example here uh let's say that
restaurant serves chicken sandwiches
I've heard similar chicken sandwiches at
another restaurant and they didn't taste
good so I don't think theirs will be the
best either so based on the example I
think you can understand so why is the
person making a
generalization and that's why it's
called the Hasty
generalization
the second one is slippery slope uh a
slippery slope is uh when a person
asserts that one occurrence leads to
another and so on uh until a terrible
conclusion is reached and uh if we uh
take an example of a slippery slope uh
it's the the one that you already have
uh on your screen uh there's this guy
who says if I don't turn this essay on
time my teacher will give me a failing
grade if I get a failing grade I might
fail the subject if I fail the subject I
have to take it again next year if I
can't do that I won't be able to
graduate on time so there's that uh very
interesting and uh very good example of
a slippery
slope the next one is ADD homonym at
hominum uh is a logical
fallacy uh which occurs when a person
uh tries to change the focus of of an
argument from the argument itself to
something about the other person so
instead of let's say attacking the
argument or how strong valid the
argument is the person tries to uh play
the person so tries to play uh the the
the speaker and not focusing on the
argument and there's this example uh if
someone supposedly says her whole argu
ment is about taking care of the
environment but he changed the subject
by taking about sorry uh he changed the
subject by talking about how she did
poorly in debate
competitions and uh there's a logical
fallacy in that
statement and another uh logical fallacy
is post Hawk ero propor Hawk and this
fallacy uh or this conclusion is based
based on the idea that if a came after B
then B must have uh caused a so there's
this chain of uh inappropriate logical
relation this logical fallacy is also
committed due to insufficient evidence
about the event so uh the speaker or the
writer is trying to shift their focus
into something uh not very important and
jumping to conclusions that are not
logical as uh as we we can see in the
example here uh that says she forgot to
bring an umbrella once and it rained a
week later when she brought an umbrella
it didn't rain so she decided to always
bring one so it wouldn't rain how how
smart that is how logical that is and uh
and uh looks like looks like that that's
it for today we uh covered a few uh the
most common logical fallacies that uh
are to be seen in Reading speaking and
uh writing passages as well uh always be
critical of what you communicate because
words have integrity just like you do
it's very it's a very good uh advice
when it comes to people who tend to
follow or Pursuit a more academic career
or life
[Music]
and uh if we wrap wrap this up this
whole uh lesson we
can review and conclude by saying that
logical fallacies are common flaws in
reasoning that weaken or invalidate your
argument logic your arguments Logic the
four most common logical errors are
Hasty generalization slipper slope at
homonym and post hog Ergo propor hog
Hasty General is when a conclusion is
drawn from a study that was done in a
hurry or with insufficient evidence
slippery slope asss that one
occurrence leads to another and so on
until a terrible conclusion is reached
and uh ad homm attacks a person rather
than the argument being talked about
post Hawk Ergo propter Haw is based on
the idea that if a came after B then B
must have caused a a so thank you for uh
watching this video and uh if you like
this content make
sure uh to subscribe like and comment
below if you have any other any other
examples of
uh Hasty generalization slippery slope
at homm uh or post hog Ergo propor hog
and thank you for watching I'll see you
next
[Music]
time